foreign
post a lot of people have been sending
this to us recently
here's what it's called
Marie condo's life is Messier now
and she's fine with it
in the chill of January we often examine
how we are living and right now many of
us are revisiting the tidying principles
of Japanese lifestyle Queen Marie condo
but the ever organized condo it seems is
a bit frazzled since giving birth to her
third child in 2021 like most of us
she's having trouble keeping up with all
of it never fear though she is still
sparking Joy
it's just that these days
that doesn't hinge on having a tidy
house her new rituals turn inward
the more thoughtful things than a drawer
full of perfectly folded t-shirts or an
instagram-worthy spice cabinet here's
what I'll say I'll put a link to the
article in the show notes so you can
read the whole thing if you'd like
this is why tidying up doesn't work it
sounds to me like what Marie kondo has
done now she's embracing minimalism
intentional living if tidying up worked
it would also work when you have three
kids the reason I knew minimalism worked
when I first embraced minimalism wasn't
because it worked simply for me but it
worked universally the people who I was
exposed to a first Courtney Carver and
her teenage daughter were minimalists
Colin Wright a single young guy in his
20s who traveled the world was a
minimalist and then I saw Leo babalta he
and his wife and their six kids were
minimalists and I realized like oh
minimalism works if you're that single
peripatetic writer who's traveling the
world but it also works if you're a
husband and wife coupled with a blended
family and six kids living intentionally
works you know what doesn't work
constantly reorganizing everything and
this is when I say tidying up doesn't
work
I think Marie kondo in her books
especially the the life-changing magic
of tidying up she acknowledges that it
goes beyond simply folding your shirts
it goes beyond
having the Instagram worthy spice
cabinet and there's nothing wrong with
having those things but universally if
you need to have the perfectly folded
shirts in your drawer otherwise you feel
like your life is chaotic
then that's not going to work once your
life is injected with a little bit of
chaos and of course parenting is the
first way to turn everything upside down
yeah but the reason minimalism still
works minimalism is the thing that gets
us past the things
so we can make a lot room for life's
most important things you get to decide
what's important to you and that could
be Parenthood it can be having all the
spices in alphabetical order in your
cabinet but you get to decide what's
important to you
and minimalism is about something much
bigger than not looking messy to other
people yes
yes because
I cannot look messy to other people and
still have a horde of stuff I can just
have it really well organized I can get
the boxes and the bins and put them in
my attic in my closet in my spare
bedroom I can have a storage unit the
biggest one they have full of stuff I
can hide my clutter and it looks tidy
but it's still there and not only is it
there physically that's not really the
problem the real problem is it's there
in my heart in my mind in my psyche it's
weighing me down it's getting in the way
and yes I can tidy up the Clutter but of
course the easiest way to organize your
stuff
is to get rid of most of it did you
enjoy this Standalone patreon highlight
if so you can listen to full episodes of
the minimalist private podcast available
exclusively on patreon visit patreon.com
the minimalists or click the link in the
description your support keeps our
podcast and YouTube Channel 100
advertisement free